قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه ناقش
مساله حل الدولتين مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو وان الاخيره
لم يعترض على هذا الحل اضاف بايدن في
تصريحات للصحفيين ان هناك عددا من الانماط
لحل الدولتين وان عده دول في الامم
المتحده ليس لديها جيوش خاصه بها واشار
الى ان هذا الحل ليس مستحيلا بوجود نتنيا
في
السلطه هناك عدد من الانماط لحل الدولتين
هناك عدد من الدول الاعضاء في الامم
المتحده التي ليس لديها جيوشها الخاصه
وهناك دول تخضع لقيود معينه لذا اعتقد ان
هناك طرقا يمكن لهذا الامر ان ينجح من
خلالها نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن مصدر مطلع
ان مسؤولي اداره الرئيس جو بايدن اجروا
مؤخرا مناقشات بشان اقامه دوله فلسطينيه
محتمله منزوعه السلاح اضاف المصدر ان
بايدن يعتقد ان اقامه دوله فلسطينيه
منزوعه السلاح فكره مثيره للاهتمام وقال
ان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنم نتنياهو
اوضح لبايدن انه لم يك لم يكن يقصد في
تصريحاته الاخيره منع امكانيه قيام دوله
فلسطينيه باي شكل من الاشكال اضاف المصدر
في تصريحاته للشبكه ان بايدن ونتنياهو
ناقش في الاتصال الاخير صفات الدوله
الفلسطينيه المستقبليه التي يجب التفاوض
بشانها